you're gonna be absolutely disgusted  when you hear about how evil this  company is this company went to poor  countries in asia and africa because  poor uneducated people are a lot easier  to manipulate then they dress up their  sales women to look like nurses and had  these nurses hand out free samples of  baby formula to breastfeeding mothers  innocent enough right but here was the  trick this company made sure that their  free samples were just big enough that  by the time the mothers ran out of this  baby formula these moms would have  stopped making breast milk naturally and  boom they now had a very loyal customer  that had no choice but to buy from them  it didn't matter that baby formula isn't  anywhere near as good for babies as real  breast milk the executives were raking  in so much dough and this company was  nestle and they did a lot of other shady  stuff too so make sure you subscribe for  part 3 and for more tutorials on how to  be evil